hi my name is Chris and I'm a hugger I'm
a cultural mediator at the LEGO Group
and let me show you the lego history
today the LEGO Group is of course known
for the Lego brick but it started out in
1932 with a production of wooden toys
the founder Awlaki Christensen he
started playing with the two Danish
words like God which means play well and
he then brought these two Danish words
together to the name of Lego in 1960 we
had a fire in our water in Factory and
because of this we made the decision to
stop the production of modern toys so
basically from 16 onwards we say let's
focus solely on the Lego brick if I have
6 bricks with the tubes in the same
color so I can combine these in nine
hundred and fifteen million one hundred
and three thousand seven hundred and
sixty-five different ways I do not have
the imagination to combine these bricks
in almost a billion ways but it is
possible in the late 90s we actually
also started to produce video games we
started to lose faith in the Lego brick
and the construction tours and we
started to spread our focus out on
various areas of our of our business we
wanted to open up new legal ends around
the world
huge tasks that takes a lot of focus
away from from our core business our
core will always be the brick and
construction force that is what we need
to focus on because that is what we are
experts
the last seven or eight years we have
had double-digit growth every year you
know that's mine bone
you